as fall breaks out in Canada I'm
reminded of all the beauty innocence and
gun free fun available from our
neighbors to the north
[Music]
there's the majesty of Toronto
[Music]
vast hockey rinks
[Music]
spectacular batches of poutine and
gallons of maple syrup that you can chug
openly and kill free for this maple
syrup is pure and nourishing
[Applause]
[Music]
the changing of the seasons also happens
to be the perfect time to encounter one
of Canada's most prized creatures the
artificial intelligence nerd
[Music]
not too long ago these beings were rare
and hidden away in university dungeons
but today they flourish they primped
with instinctual grace they wave their
hands impressively to assert their
intellectual dominance they carve load
like overpaid professional athletes and
this makes some sense because they're
among the best paid professionals in the
world
[Music]
together these creatures did something
truly remarkable without anyone paying
much notice they gave birth to an AI
revolution they turned Canada
yes Canada into one of the great AI
superpowers this is the story of how all
this came to be it's the story of one
nations quest to teach computers to
think like humans it's the story of what
this science experiment will mean for
all our lives and for the future of the
human species
so if you're a human or something trying
to imitate one you'll want to pay
attention
[Music]
ever since people first came up with the
idea of computers they've dreamed of
imbuing them with artificial
intelligence I am a smart fellow as I
have a very fine brain that's the most
remarkable thing I've ever seen
AI is just a computer that is able to
mimic or simulate human thought or human
behavior within that there's a subset
called machine learning that it's now
the underpinning of what is most
exciting about AI by allowing computers
to learn how to solve problems on their
own machine learning has made a series
of breakthroughs that once seemed nearly
impossible
it's the reason computers can understand
your voice spot of friends face in a
photo and steer a car
and it's the reason people are actively
talking about the arrival of human-like
AI and whether that would be a good
thing for a horrific end of days thing
many people made this moment possible
but one figure towers above the rest
I've come to the University of Toronto
to see the man they call the Godfather
of modern artificial intelligence geoff
hinton because of a back condition geoff
hinton hasn't been able to sit down for
more than 12 years I hate standing as
much all the time but if I said I never
did seconds I'm sorry well at least no
standing desks are fashionable and yeah
but I was the head I was standing where
I was standing when they were final
since he can't sit in the car or on a
bus
Hinton walks everywhere
[Music]
the walk says a lot about Hinton and his
results for nearly 40 years
Hinton has been trying to get computers
to learn like people do a quest almost
everyone thought was crazy or at least
hopeless right up until the moment it
revolutionized the field google thinks
this is the future of the company I was
in theis Tunisian company Apple thinks
its future healthy my own department
thinks this does probably nonsense and
we shouldn't be doing any more so I took
everybody into it except my own
department
you obviously grew up in the UK and you
had this very prestigious family full of
famous mathematicians and economists and
I was I was curious what it was like for
you yeah there was a lot of pressure I
think by the time I was about 7 I
realized I was gonna have to get a PhD
did you rebel against that are you you
had a long drop down every so often yeah
I became a carpenter for a while chef
Hansen pretty early on became obsessed
with this idea of figuring out how the
mind works
he started off getting into physiology
the anatomy of how the brain works then
he got into psychology and then finally
he settled on more of a computer science
approach to modeling the brain and got
into artificial intelligence my feeling
is if you want to understand a really
complicated device like a brain you
should build one I mean you could look
at cars and you could think you could
understand cars when you try and build a
car you suddenly discover then there's
this stuff that has to go under the hood
otherwise it doesn't work
yeah
as Jeff was starting to think about
these ideas he got inspired by some AI
researchers across the pond specifically
this guy Frank Rosenblatt Rosenblatt in
the late 1950s developed what he called
a perceptron and it was a neural network
a computing system that would mimic the
brain the basic idea is a collection of
small units called neurons these are
little computing units but they're
actually modeled on the way that the
human brain does its computation they
take incoming data like we do from our
senses and they actually learn so the
neural net can learn to make decisions
over time Rosenblatt's hope was that you
could feed a neural network a bunch of
data like pictures of men and women and
it would eventually learn how to tell
them apart just like humans do
there was just one problem it didn't
work very well
Rosenblatt his neural network was the
single layer of neurons and it was
limited in what it could do extremely
limited and a colleague of his wrote a
book in the late 60s that showed these
limitations and it kind of put the whole
area of research into a deep freeze for
a good ten years no one wanted to work
in this area they were sure it would
never work well almost no one
it was just obvious to me that it was
right where to go the brains are big
neural network and so it has to be that
stuff like this can work because it
works in our brains there's just never
any doubt about that now what do you
think it was inside of you that kept you
on him to pursue this when everyone else
was giving up just that you thought it
was the right direction to go was wrong
okay Hinton decides he's got an idea of
how these neural nets might work and
he's gonna pursue it no matter what for
a little while he's bouncing around
research institutions in the u.s. he
kind of gets fed up that most of them
are funded by the Defense Department and
he starts looking for somewhere else he
can go I didn't want to take Defense
Department money I sort of didn't like
the idea that this stuff was gonna be
used for purposes like didn't think
we're good
he suddenly here's the Canada might be
interested in funding artificial
intelligence and that was very
attractive
but I could go off to this civilized
town and just get on with so I came to
the University on toe and then in the
mid-80s we discovered how to make more
complicated neural nets so they could
solve those problems that the simple
ones couldn't solve
he and his collaborators developed a
multi-layer neural network a deep neural
network and this started to work in a
lot of ways using a neural network a guy
named Dean Pomerleau built a
self-driving car in the late 80s and it
drove on public roads yawn laocoön in
the 90s built a system that could
recognize handwritten digits and this
ended up being used commercially but
again they hit a ceiling didn't work
quite well enough because we didn't have
enough data we didn't have enough
compute power and people in AI in
computer science and society neural
networks was wishful thinking recently
so it was a big disappointment through
the dinies into the 2000s jeff was one
of only a handful of people on the
planet who were still pursuing this
technology he would show up at academic
conferences and be banished to the back
rooms he was treated as really like a
pariah was there like a time when you
thought this just wasn't gonna work and
and you didn't have some self-doubt I
mean either many times when I thought
I'm not gonna make this work but Jeff
was consumed by this and couldn't stop
he just kept pursuing the idea that
computers could learn until about 2006
when the world catches up to Hinton's
ideas
[Music]
Computers with our la casa and now it's
behaving like I thought it will behave
in the mid-80s it's solving everything
the arrival of super fast chips and the
massive amounts of data produced on the
internet gave Hinton's algorithms a
magical boost
suddenly computers could identify what
was in an image then they could
recognize speech and translate from one
language to another by 2012 words like
neural Nets and machine learning we're
popping up on the front page of the New
York Times you have to go all these
years and then all of a sudden you know
in the span of a few months
yes takes off and did it finally feel
like aha you know the world has finally
come to my vision this sort of a relief
that people finally came to their senses
next up we have professor Geoffrey
Hinton of the University of Toronto
[Applause]
[Music]
for hinton this is obviously a really
redemptive poet now he's basically a
technology celebrity and for Canada it's
the country's moment as well they have
more AI researchers than just about any
other place on the planet and the quest
now is to see what these guys can do
starting companies and pushing the
technology forward I'm gonna set out on
a journey across Canada to see the best
in Canadian AI technology and to get a
feel for how far the technology has come
and how far it still has to go
here is a city that gets right at the
central tension of modern life and the
unfolding AI revolution
[Music]
it's Montreal a place filled with beauty
and old-world charms that ask you to
move slowly through its streets and to
chill for a while
reflect and think deep thoughts
at the same time it's one of the world's
top AI research centers students flock
here from all over the globe to get deep
with machine learning and to take Jeff
Hinton's ideas and figure out how to
turn them into products we all use to
see just how successful they've been
look no further than your pilot all this
stuff started out as hardcore computer
science but over the last five years
AI has invaded our everyday lives your
smartphone is packed full of AI powered
apps including something like Google
Translate that lets you point your phone
at a magazine that's written in french
and read it as if you were a local
engineers have been trying to get
computers to translate text like this
for decades but it was Jeff's neural
nets that finally made it possible
thanks Jeff and it's not just your
smartphone neural networks are heading
for the open road off we go
me by friends Stephane the head of
Montreal's Tesla fan club I'm driving a
Tesla for a little bit more than for you
on that hand do you have people asking
you for rides all the time yes maybe
that's because of his fancy-pants
autopilot Tesla semi autonomous driving
system that kicks in when road
conditions are right so that's it
autopilot on yes and it's driving by
yourself we need to pay attention that's
we don't have to drive crazy
[Music]
self-driving cars are packed full of
cameras sensors and radar when teamed
with computer vision neural nets it's
this technology that lets the cars build
a picture of the world the technology
has a long way to go but this Tesla can
monitor all the cars around it switch
lanes and park all by itself thanks Jeff
so you're living in the future yeah you
know when you try it once it's very
difficult to do without it because I
just can't be relaxed that's why we
still need to pay attention back on the
sidewalk I tap those neural Nets again
this time in the form of speech
recognition find me some poutine a
speech recognition used to suck but now
it's pretty darn good why under all that
of course thanks Jeff
[Music]
the Google brain sent me here for an
artery hardening affair with poutine
once a simple Quebec dish of cheese
curds french fries and gravy it's been
disrupted the dan dan
pepperoni bacon and onions here we go
it's gooey glorious and blessedly
algorithm free
well now the humans are toast when they
can make stuff like this
[Music]
a big part of Henson's legacy lies
beyond these examples of AI in the world
he's also inspired a legion of disciples
spreading the good word of neural nets
yoshua bengio is a professor at the
university of montreal he's one of the
researchers who glommed on to Hinton's
ideas what it seemed to make little
sense to do so over the years he's
formed a mind-meld with Hinton and
together they've come up with many of
the key concepts behind modern AI you
guys worked on this stuff through the
80s 90s the 2000s and then it just
seemed like this totally went from
computer science and research to we see
it everywhere in our lives or you know
or even you surprised what's happened
the last five years that it really is
like sitting on all our phones and that
the rate at which the progress and the
industrial products have been coming out
is totally something we didn't expect
even now it's hard to predict where are
we going is it gonna slow down or are we
gonna continue with this exponential
increase
it's thanks to Yahshua that Montreal is
full of top-notch AI Graduate talent
this in turn has brought tech giants
like Google and Facebook to town along
with their ample checkbooks to me it
seems like if you're good at AI you can
make two three hundred thousand dollars
a year
this is crazy to see how much these guys
get paid now a million dollar is
something quite common as a sorry have
you ever had a country offer you an
incredible money to come set up a lab
they're not a country but yeah companies
you know but Yahshua has rejected the
lucrative offers of big neural net he
remains committed to the ivory towers of
academia which is a better fit for his
philosophical approach to AI you've got
guys like Elon Musk and Stephen Hawking
and sometimes paint this technology in a
very very dark light that it could run
amuck and start doing things on its own
but you know what do you feel when you
hear people say things like that I'm not
concerned about technology running amuck
of the Terminator scenario I think is
not very credible and I also believe
that if we're able to build machines
that are as small as us they also smart
enough to understand our values and to
understand our moral system and and so
act in a way that's good for us now I
think there are real concerns which is
essentially misuse of AI to influence
people's minds it's already happening
with political advertising yeah we've
already seen like the stuff from
Facebook I think we should be careful
about this
and try to regulate the use of AI in
places where it's morally wrong
ethically wrong I think we just should
just ban it and make it you know illegal
[Music]
it's comforting that Yahshua has these
concerns but hop down the road from the
University and reality or what's left of
it it becomes Messier this tiny room is
the home to a startup called Lyrebird it
was founded by Yahshua's former students
and has built an app that can clone your
voice are you speaking about this new
algorithm to copy voices this is huge it
can make us say anything now really
anything one of its founders is this guy
mexican expat Jose he taught me the art
of the clove so you will need to record
yourself for a few minutes of audio
thousands of letters danced across the
amateur author screen when you start to
eat like this something is the matter
you guys better quit politics and take
in washing I don't know where that work
here probably
okay so create my digital voice now try
a ting your digital voice takes at least
one minute one minute my god yeah so
before to create some artificial voice
of someone you would need to record
yourself for on at least eight hours
test your voice alright so now I get the
types of day yeah so the moment of truth
what's lyrebirds AI has worked it's
magic
after I'm done typing spell letter any
words I put into the app can be played
back in my digital voice and here's the
crazy thing even words I never actually
said in the first place
artificial intelligence technology seems
to be advancing very quickly should we
be afraid I mean I can definitely hear
by voice in there that's what that is
that's really interesting I just picked
those words at random and I definitely
did not say some of them and it's like
flawless and being able to sort of pick
from just about any word and manufacture
it never seen this technology seems
sweet but lends itself to all manner of
trickery
[Applause]
I've popped back to my hotel to test out
the library technology a little bit and
you could see some really obvious ways
that this could be abused this is fake
Donald Trump talking the United States
is considering in addition to other
options stopping all trade with any
country doing business with North Korea
and then you did picture somebody taking
over your voice and creating some mayhem
in your personal life now to really put
my computer voice to the test I am going
to call my dear sweet mother and see if
she recognizes me hey mom what are you
guys up to today I'm just finishing up
work and waiting for the boys to get
home okay I think I'm coming down with a
virus I was messing around with you you
were talking to a computer amazing is
that scary you're good it could be scary
if it was something really important are
you now is the - oh I don't know is it
[Music]
after realizing that anyone with the
time and inclination could mess with my
life there was only one thing left to do
I joined Jose and a few other lyrebirds
to chat more about the evils of AI while
dulling my fear with booze obviously
some people are freaked out by this
technology because we're already like
blurring the line about truth in reality
of course there is some risk in in in
people using this kind of technology for
bad applications
unfortunately technologies it's not
possible to stop it so the ethical path
that we have decided is to show these to
people to make them know that this kind
of technology is available and so to
make them more cautious on this kind of
a subject we really believe that right
now when the technology is not perfect
is the right time to let people kind of
play with it get used to it slowly so
you guys think the idea is just sort of
new and that's what scares people but if
you get used to it it's just that's just
the way it is we want our technology to
be used for for positive things it's not
something that we should be really
afraid of it's something that we should
be careful about but I feel enthusiastic
about
[Music]
it's nice to be enthusiastic it's also
nice to meditate on the consequences of
your inventions instead of turning our
souls over to chance and blind luck well
it is kind of cool to be a cynical
bastard in my new artisanal computer
voice welcome Russian friends to our
huge wonderful and very pure elections
[Music]
the real artificial intelligence weirdos
in Canada live here in Edmonton
[Music]
this is a large but very very cold Xin
very very flat city that is more or less
in the middle of nowhere it's the kind
of place that has a giant butter vault
to help people survive the lean winter
months
Canadians like to put the best possible
spin on how these conditions bring out
interesting traits in people ask anyone
like this guy from the Edmonton tourist
center Edmonton's of one of those cities
that isn't you know automatically listed
in the top cities in Canada in terms of
size or scale or notice even but it's
always had a really neat quality to it
of that Western independent spirit that
you see very much in in Alberta in
general combined with a conscience and a
thoughtfulness over the University of
Alberta some of the most far-out AI
research in the world is taking place
the man I'm here to see is the
university's very own AI godfather rich
Sutton rich is considered one of the
great revolutionary thinkers in AI you
are not Canadian I am Canadian but not
by birth no I was born in the US but now
I'm just Canadian okay and what brought
you to Canada the politics I wanted to
get away from difficult times in the
United States the United States was
invading other countries in 2003 when I
came here and I didn't care for all that
sudden entered the field of AI in the
mid 80s and like Geoff Hinton and yoshua
bengio
he was a big believer in neural networks
but Sutton has a different idea about
how to further the technology unlike
Henson's method of feeding neural
networks reams and reams of data and
telling them what to do Sutton wants
them to learn more naturally from
experience an approach called
reinforcement learning
we're reinforcement learning it's like
when animals do and what people do try
several things the things that work best
you keep doing those and things that
don't work out so well you stop doing
them and how do you teach your computer
Wow well you know idea all you need is a
sense the computer has to have a sense
of what's good and what's bad and so you
give it a special signal call the reward
if the reward is high that means it's
good reward as well that means it's bad
to see reinforcement learning in action
I found Marlowe's an industrious young
Brazilian who's created an AI to play
his video games for him his algorithm
plays the game thousands of times and
gradually learns from experience how to
do better so the goal of this game is
that you are a dizzy yellow blob and
what you have to do is that you have to
get as many potions as you can why
avoiding harpies and this is like the AI
going at this for the first time it's
day I run it for the first time so just
bumps into things if it gets points it's
happy if it dies it's unhappy yes and
the eye starts to figure out that maybe
what I want to do is to collect this
potions and avoid the harpies and now we
can look at AI that has ran for 5,000
games ok and this is what it looks like
you can tell that it's smarter about its
strategy yes then what happens if you
run it 500,000 times oh we got you the
super human performance and level so
notching a high score is the noblest of
pursuits reinforcement learning has
turned out to have all kinds of other
applications it's behind the algorithm
that recommends movies and TV shows on
Netflix and Amazon
it beat the world champion go player a
feat previously thought impossible for a
computer soon it could read your
brainwaves and determine whether you
have a mental disorder but for Sutton
all that is just the beginning we are
trying to make real intelligence we're
trying to recreate human intelligence
humans are our example he sees
reinforcement learning as the path to
what futurists call the singularity the
moment when our AI creations light up
and surge past human level intelligence
do you have a date for the singularity
or so you give you a it's a it's a quite
broad probability distribution and the
median is at twenty forty twenty that
was equal chance being before after
twenty forty okay
the rationale goes like this by 2030
we'll have the hardware so give guys
like me another 10 years to figure out
the algorithms yeah software to go with
the hardware to do it it's gonna be
exciting where we're going
if 2040 seems like a long time to wait
to meet a smart robot do not fret over
in the experimental wing of the
university there are coeds hard at work
blurring the line between humans and
machines are you human case in point
homegrown Edmund tawny ingenious Cory
Matthews
tell me about this guy a little bit yeah
sure so this is blueberry on blueberry
I've deployed the improv system so
there's an artificial improv system
running on blueberry right now yes
that's right Cory does improv comedy
with a robot I've been doing improv
longer than I've been doing computing
science I've been doing it for 12 years
and I thought you know there's no more
natural convergence than taking some of
these state-of-the-art systems and
putting them up on stage like a
ventriloquist earth is like a new-age
strange twist on it the piece that's
different
is that I don't know what it will say
anything that comes from the system it's
generating live-in-the-moment blueberry
I I created you I downloaded a voice
into your brain so that you could
perform in front of these people I don't
know what you're gonna say either to
give blueberry the power of surreal
Canadian improv Corey made use of some
tech that should be familiar by now a
neural network
step one he feeds the network the
dialogue from a bunch of movies one
hundred two thousand movies to be exact
all the movies every movie for a hundred
years and that's just so I can learn
language see how somebody responds to
somebody else that's exactly right yeah
it builds kind of a language model step
two he uses reinforcement learning to
train the network rewarding it when it
makes sense and punishing it when it
spits out gibberish time to put this
wannabe kid in the hall to the test yeah
start improvising okay campers we're
gonna get ready for a real baseball game
grab your gloves and grab your baseball
bats and let's get out there especially
you Franklin okay okay well why aren't
you ready for the match okay come on
Franklin you know how I feel about you
but you got to keep your head in the
game right now oh Jesus put down the bat
Franklin what are you doing hi I've got
nothing to hide
look this is all I am okay obviously
some of the responses are a little bit
weird but then it's really funny because
then as you're going along it did hit a
couple things perfectly and then it's
like yeah I mean it's extra hilarious
because oh yeah that's going
blueberry may not be ready for its
second city audition just yet but Cory
has a higher purpose making AI relatable
there is fear in society of AI so we are
kind of humanizing this AI we're taking
it down a peg we're saying don't be
afraid of this tech look at how cute it
is look at how kind of naive it is
[Music]
there's no flipside to that though then
you make it cute and and then people
start to accept it and you know then
then we wake up I don't think that will
happen in my time the singularity may be
near or it may be not so near but if the
inhabitants of this oddly beautiful
place keep pushing the technology they
just might create something alarmingly
human-like one day for rich Sutton it's
not a question of whether we'll get
there but whether we'll be able to
accept our mechanized brethren our
society will be will be challenged you
know it's just like every time you know
our black people people our women people
we will do the same thing with robots
eventually are they allowed to own
property are they allowed to earn an
income or do they have to be owned by
somebody but a robot's obviously about a
person right
No
[Laughter]
[Music]
for my last stop I returned to Toronto
home to 2.8 million people one very tall
tower and of course the Godfather
himself inside the system there's also
little processes which are a little bit
like brain cells he may be an import but
geoff hinton has done something truly
exceptional for toronto he's turned the
city into an AI mecca where AI
conferences like this one seems to take
place daily
[Music]
and we're young minds come to show off
their ideas Canada if we're being honest
doesn't usually seem that intimidating
but thanks to Jeff it's got nothing less
than world domination in mind we are
enormous ly thankful to Canadians for
inventing all this stuff because we now
use it throughout our entire business
should never save this record that he
owes that Google owes can absolutely
that was a mistake the tech industry is
full of people who adore AI and then
also some famous types like Elon Musk
and Stephen Hawking who said well the
day I might be the end of us to consider
such dystopia in the proper light I've
come to Toronto's geekiest bar to encase
myself in this steel container with
George divorce key he's a writer for
Gizmodo and an AI philosopher
[Music]
well since we're in laughs apocalyptic
bar what is the the con case around AI
what's what's the nastiest scenario that
everybody's worried about
unfortunately there's there's no
shortage of nasty scenarios and this I
think this is what makes artificial
intelligence such a scary thing is all
that different ways that it can go wrong
it can be everything from an accident
you know where we just didn't think it
through we gave a very powerful computer
instructions to do something we thought
we explained it articulately we thought
we gave it a concrete goal and it
completely took a different path than we
thought it would in such a way that it
actually caused some great damage I'm
sure you've heard the old paper clip
example where you're a paper clip
manufacturer and you say hey we need
lots of paper clips and because they're
artificial intelligence has so much
reach and so much power it actually
starts to go about converting all of the
matter and all the molecules on the
planet into paper clips before you know
it we've now converted the entire cosmos
into paper clips that's a crazy scenario
but it's an illustrative scenario we
can't be dismissive of the perils I
think that's sex exceptionally dangerous
and I don't think it's too early to
start raising the alarm bells about it
being turned into Clippy sounds awful
but fear not
we'll have years to ease into that sort
of suffering as AI steadily plucks off
one job after another
the first to go of course will likely be
the always screwed factory workers which
brings us to Suzanne Gilbert a budding
AI overlord and founder of robotics
start-up kindred AI tell me about these
guys so these are research prototypes so
there's some of the first robots we
built at kindred we tend to work with
small robots it's a bit like if you
imagine a a child growing up and it
breaks a lot of things now imagine if
the child was 6 feet tall when it had
the brain of a six-month-old it would be
terrible terribly dangerous how many of
these robots have a very slapped year I
have been hit in the face by a robots a
couple of suzi it seems nice enough
she makes exotic digital arts and she
loves cats to the point where she's
built a robotic fleet of them for the
office this one I believe is called pink
foot it's a Quadra pedra bot loosely
based on a cat and that's me although
it's not a very highly faithful
representation yet and then when you
were growing up you would build things
as well yeah that's correct yeah so I
was really enthralled by electronics at
an early age I guess most little girls
would be looking at trays of beads and
things and I was looking at trays of
white resistors and capacitors and
little components but having the same
kind of reaction to them but don't be
fooled by the hobby electronics and the
cute cat BOTS Suzanne is a keen
businesswoman and kindred has recently
embarked on its first commercial venture
what's going on here is we have a bank
of robots that are learning so they are
continuously running picking up objects
these would run all day all day all
night powered by a neural network these
arms can do something that's very easy
for a human but very hard for a bot pick
up objects of different shapes and put
them down most factories still use
people to do that sort of thing lots and
lots of people today everyone's shopping
on ecommerce
thousands and thousands of different
types of objects shapes textures weights
how do you pick it up right now as
humans you have millions of humans in
warehouses just like picking up things
and putting it into another location so
we're teaching our robots how to do that
[Music]
what's the hard part it's figuring out
what's a belt what's a shirt or it's
just how to grasp it exactly how to pick
it up right so things will show up in
any shape right and you gotta figure out
how to pick it up without dropping it
put it in the location so takes a lot of
train
part of the training involves of all
things humans robot pilots who manually
control the arms while the AI watches
and learns the finer points of grabbing
fireman
teach me are you okay have a seat so you
see a 3d mouse here this lets you
navigate the arm through
three-dimensional space
so imagine you're holding the arm in
that left hand and you're just moving it
around move it slowly gently there you
go
try get the Oreos I gotta go
Oh shoes though I went too far okay
basically actually just down the hall
kindred keeps a room full of pilots
doing the same thing as me only these
guys are actually competent they're
remotely overseeing some arms in a Gap
Factory a thousand miles away in
Tennessee how long have you been a robot
pilot uh just over a month actually I've
only been here five weeks what was the
training process like almost like
playing a video game like your shirt
god that's a backpack that's a backpack
okay somebody's undies oh there it goes
yeah one shirt at a time
as the arms observe their human guides
they gradually learn how to do better at
picking up t-shirts and shoe boxes
eventually they'll be fully autonomous
and size services will no longer be
required one day this is just gonna
light up and it's gonna be picking the
objects pretty pretty much that's that's
the ultimate end goal for at least for
these to have it just constantly were in
and go in and the people will be free
the people will be free to do other more
important so I seemed kind of happy
about the prospect of unemployment but I
was concerned for his future
[Music]
is there something grim about the human
training there yeah it's not good to
take people's jobs away but this kind of
technology coming into the workforce
should make us start thinking about how
we're going to pay people in the future
because AI is not just going to automate
you know manual labor jobs it's gonna
automate things like doctors and lawyers
and accountants very soon so I think
there's gonna be issues there's gonna be
a lot of disruption when these things
come online Suzanne is a realist but
she's also an optimist in her vision of
the future robots won't be mindless
competitors to humanity
they'll be full-fledged citizens like
the rest of us one of the crazy ideas
Ozu talked about was you've got a robot
and just working in a factory and then
it's got to go maybe it gets paid a wage
and it goes to buy lithium ion batteries
to keep it going why would that have to
happen I mean are you having a physical
body they will have a lot of physical
needs just like we have you might have
to go to the repair shop
to get like a motor loop table or
something like that and they'll have to
pay someone to do that I think they'll
just be contributing to our economy in
the same way we do
and if they have brains like us they'll
want to explore new things I've never
seen before they'll want to learn things
they'll want to perhaps rest so that
their mind has time to consolidate all
this new information I should keep
trying to picture hit my head though so
this is the robot workers they go home
and sit on the couch watch TV after work
it is I don't see why not
videos it's hard to tell sometimes if
Suzanne is laughing with us paratus
but she's not alone in her cautious
optimism for the future I think there's
always a sense that you know technology
can be either used for good or used for
bad I'm reassured that that Canada is
part of it in terms of trying to set us
on the right path on the whole being
responsible and thoughtful about the
power we're gaining by research and
learning is the right trendline and I
don't think a ice automatically doomed
to some dystopian outcome we're told
that politicians will come up with
policies that address massive job loss
and prevent horrific inequality between
the classes and we're told that these
guys will take so long to become
human-like that we need not be afraid
for a while the truth though is that
we're turning ourselves over to the
unknown here so you know fingers crossed
eventually I think we will become da is
we would become the intelligent machines
we will understand how things can be
smart and we can literally create them
so it's you might think of it as making
a new generation new kinds of people
humanity is continuing to evolve and why
wouldn't enhance people or even designed
people be the next step in humanity it's
really hard to predict the future I
think there's gonna be all sorts of
things happen we didn't expect but
there's one thing that we can predict
this technology is going to change
everything goodbye goodbye goodbye once
I power you down that's it yeah that's
right we'll end it right there
[Music]
thanks for watching and if you want to
see more hello world click on the link
to subscribe